all i see is a big old flame
hey crazies i recently got a thermal
camera let's explore the realm of
infrared
also thanks to brilliant for helping
support this episode
on twitter i asked you what i should
look at in infrared and you did not
disappoint the replies were both helpful
and hilarious
sorry to say i will not be slapping a
chicken until it's cooked
farts i consider this one but they're
not exactly something you can plan for
but checking out my home insulation
seems easy enough let's start there
since that'll give us a better idea of
what we're looking at
what you're seeing here is infrared
light or at least a visual
representation of infrared light humans
can't see infrared light in fact we
barely see any light at all
our visible range goes from red up to
violet that's a small range of
wavelengths and a very narrow sliver of
the electromagnetic energy spectrum
infrared means below red so infrared
light is the range just below red on the
spectrum it also happens to be the type
of light emitted by things at ordinary
temperatures
so when you've got a camera sensitive to
that range it lets you see temperature
it takes that infrared data and shifts
it up to the visible range for your
screen
here you can actually see one of my
heating ducts is behind this exterior
wall
you can see through walls with that
thing i mean i i can see why you would
think that but but no it can't see
through walls
you're still only seeing the exterior of
my house it's just that this spot is
warmer than the rest of the exterior
wall the same goes for this image of my
studio you're not actually seeing the
studs it's just that the studs make
those spots on the wall cooler
how heat conduction
there are three ways thermal energy can
move around conduction convection and
radiation
radiation in this context just means
light that's how the thermal camera can
see from a distance it's also how the
sun gives the earth energy the term
radiation just means the stuff being
radiated the stuff being emitted outward
not all radiation is bad for you
convection is what happens when you
cycle heat around in a fluid water
boiling in a pot does it a fancy oven
can do it with fans
technically all ovens do it it's kind of
unavoidable when there's a fluid around
convection ovens just do it better
it even happens with the plasma inside
the sun
but that's not the type you're seeing in
my exterior walls
that's conduction which requires
physical contact you can see where my
heating duct is because the duct is in
contact with my exterior wall
you can see where the studs are in my
studio because they physically connect
the exterior wall to the interior wall
notice that you can't see the studs when
both sides of the wall are inside the
house
you cannot see through walls with
infrared light you big creeper
oddly though you can't see through
windows either
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway the temperature change from
conduction can linger for longer than
you might expect
if i touch the wall for a bit and remove
my hand it takes time for that heat to
transfer into the surrounding wall and
air
the same goes for your footprints on the
floor the heat from your feet lingers
with everything you touch you're leaving
a little something behind
how that works is governed by the heat
equation this is a differential equation
which is just a fancy way of saying it's
a pattern that involves changes
this one relates changes in temperature
over time at a particular location to
differences in temperature between
nearby locations the bigger the
difference the faster the change and
vice versa it tells us how we'd expect
the heat to move around inside of a
solid body
but the specifics depend entirely on the
initial conditions
say we've got a uniformly heated rod
[Music]
since there's no temperature difference
between any nearby locations the heat
equation tells us temperature can't
change over time
in other words there's nowhere for the
heat to flow it just stays its current
temperature
a more interesting scenario would be two
uniform rods one warmer and one cooler
if the rods are brought into contact
we'd like to know what happens
our instincts tell us that the heat
would flow from the hot rod into the
cold rod and we'd be right but that
doesn't give us very much detail
applying the heat equation we can see
the fastest change starts at the contact
point over time the heat gradually
distributes throughout both rods until
they reach an equilibrium where they're
all the same temperature that all sounds
great but as experiment clone found out
a few days ago reality doesn't always
work out so nice
[Music]
both both of them have given up the
ghost
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
all i see is a big
[Music]
[Music]
as you can see the experiment didn't
work out as expected
i mean the propane flame was pretty
wicked but the cooler rod didn't
actually heat up that much it got a
little warmer at the contact point but
that's about it
we're gonna try but but even if we can't
fix this problem we need to at least
figure out why there's a problem because
frankly i hate it when i don't
understand something
our first thought was that maybe it'd be
easier to see on a big metal plate
instead
[Music]
it kind of worked
a large white spot formed as heat
quickly spread through the metal plate
but that spot is pretty difficult to see
when the rest of the plate is already
bright yellow
that means the plate was already hot
before we even started the experiment
awkward m had the good idea to bring the
plate indoors so we could cool it down
first
unfortunately by then we were running
out of propane plus experiment clone and
i were on the verge of a meltdown so
everybody decided we'd had enough
why was the plate already hot because it
was 85 degrees fahrenheit outside the
environment is our problem the
experiment isn't isolated enough
in the experiment with the two rods we
can see the ground is already hot
because it's been in the sun
the weirdest part the clamp holding the
cooler rod is hotter than that rod
honestly the black part of the clamp is
like hotter than the rod
super main ultimate point there aren't
just two rods coming into contact
there's also tongs an iron clamp the sun
the ground and the surrounding air
reality is complicated okay but i refuse
to give up let's take another look at
that heat equation
how well temperature diffuses through a
substance is measured by its thermal
diffusivity this well-named parameter is
actually a combination of two others you
may have heard of
thermal conductivity the substance's
ability to conduct heat
and volumetric heat capacity the amount
of heat it takes to change the
temperature
why does heat capacity matter because
temperature and heat are not the same
thing heat is just another name for the
flow of thermal energy but the same
amount of energy doesn't necessarily
result in the same temperature change
that's where heat capacity comes in
think of heat capacity as a tank and
thermal energy is some fluid temperature
is labeled up the side of the tank
as more of that energy fluid is added
temperature increases but not all
substances have the same size tank
a larger tank means the substance has a
larger heat capacity which means more
energy is needed to increase the
temperature
how temperature diffuses through a
substance depends on that just as much
as conductivity
where was i again
right solving the experiment problem we
just need to touch our hot rod to
something with a lower diffusivity
i think that line is the worst defender
we just need to touch our hot rods to
something with a lower diffusivity
that should slow the conduction down a
bit so we can see it happen in real time
how about some wood
wood's thermal diffusivity is several
orders of magnitude smaller than
aluminum that should do nicely
[Music]
it's definitely hot in that spot though
that is a hot spot
the temperature of the wood has
increased
if he had left the rod there longer the
environment still would have become an
issue it's kind of unavoidable but the
lower diffusivity of wood actually made
this possible to see in the short term
it's amazing what you can do with some
scientific thought
if you'd like some more experience with
that today's sponsor brilliant can help
brilliant is an interactive tool for
learning stem that lets you play with
concepts in real time
working with science yourself can really
help make it stick in your memory
if you liked this video you might like
their scientific thinking course where
they have exercises exploring heat flow
amongst other things
but maybe you're looking for something a
little more advanced they also have a
course called differential equations too
where there's a quiz on the heat
equation a major aspect of today's video
brilliant allows you to learn something
new at your own pace or on the go
to get started with a free trial go to
brilliant.org science asylum or click on
the link in the description below
the first 200 of you will get 20 off
brilliant's annual premium subscription
it'll also let brilliant know you heard
about them from me which helps out the
channel
so what would you look at with a thermal
camera i already have a few other ideas
planned for this thing
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to my patreon
patrons and youtube members like medic
hertz who's been pledging at the
einsteinium level for over a year and a
half
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
did you make this video so you could
justify the camera as a business expense
only partly
no entanglement can't be used to
communicate faster than light when you
measure your half of the entanglement
you immediately know what the other
person will measure for theirs but you
can't choose the result you'll get it's
completely random which means it can't
be used to send messages anyway thanks
for watching